thank you  thank you all for the benefit of those  members that are joining us  on YouTube  the councilor decided to pursue a  variety of sites in and around the  forage area to potentially develop as  affordable housing uh the first one I  just couldn't delete them through it's  12 12 items the Pines Lane carriages in  Biddeford  garages at Tucker's Park Bradley  land at the Crescent Langtry  land Acquired and ruled booty food  jackets Lane and Northern  the end of apple and brain close in  Biddeford  Windmill Lane offices and car park in  Northern  Boone Hill car park in Northern  Springfield car park Checkers Road  bideford  State Street car park for Torrington  and land at Cleveland  it doesn't necessarily mean that these  will be developed and built on but  feasibility studies will be undertaken  to see the viability of those fights and  reports will come back  thank you very much